[Musique]
c'est à la préfecture que se sont donné
rendez-vous le préfet la région le
département le rectorat et des
associations pour présenter des actions
pour les journées nationales contre
l'illettrisme du 8 au 15 septembre
le constat les prises de conscience sont
au rendez vous déjà l'état gbagbo libye
lise toutes les énergies pour pour
valoriser déjà pour porter des projets
au cours de la semaine nationale de
lutte contre l'illettrisme dont qui a
lieu du 8 au 15 septembre 2019 mais
également l'état un rôle d'impulsion
tout au long de l'année
pour lutter contre ce fléau qu'est
l'illettrisme dans les autres mers en
général mais à la réunion aussi en
particulier et nous devons tous nous
mobiliser
on ne doit pas rejeter la faute sur les
oies sur les autres c'est ce que disait
monsieur le recteur doute à l'heure
chacun selon ses compétences à sa
responsabilité dans cette prévention et
dans cette lutte
mais il est important d'être unis la
jouer collectif d'être innovant
ambitieux pour vraiment viser à terme à
l'éradication de ce fléau
l'illettrisme concerne 23 % de la
population réunionnaise soit environ 107
bill personnes sur notre territoire la
lutte contre l'illettrisme est une
priorité qui concerne tous les acteurs
publics et privés et mobilisé des moyens
importants
la première chose c'est de faire en
sorte que l'école produit de moins en
moins d'illettrés la première chose à
faire vous mêmes chaussettes se dit
lee sang des associations mettent toutes
leurs moyens place l'argent nous manque
quoi on a assez de moyens comment faire
en sorte les gens retrouvent goût pour
pouvoir apprendre à lire et écrire
c'est important de leur vie ce important
forcément de ma réussir dans la vie dont
il faut faire une espèce de révolution
des mentalités
oui non ou j'ai une envie forcément
d'avancé avions envie d'apprendre
pour nous pour nos familles qui sont à
l'école et si on a à côté de moi ni
pouvoirs publics une vraie envie nous en
sortir l'on pourra demain espérer enfin
d'arriver résultat positif une trentaine
d'actions labellisées seront organisées
à la réunion dans le cadre des journées
nationales d'action contre l'illettrisme
qui auront lieu du 8 au 15 septembre
prochain
[Musique]